لا تكاد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تنتهين
من اقتحام لمدينه جنين ومخيمها شماليه
الضفه الغربيه حتى تبدا اخر والهدف ذاته
في كل مره استهداف حاله المقاومه
المتصاعده هناك احدث الاقتحامات جاءت حين
تسللت قوات اسرائيليات خاصه بملابس مدنيه
الى مخيم الجنين لتنفيذ عمليه اغتيال
اسفرت عن استشهاد اربعه فلسطينيين من
بينهم القياديين بسرايا القدس وكتائب
القسام نضال خازم ويوسف الشريم اضافه الى
احد اطفال المخيم
اثر العمليه اندلعت اشتباكات عنيفه بين
مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال التي
اقتحمت المخيم باعداد كبيره لحمايه القوات
الخاصه واخراجها من المخيم
بوصفها مركزا للعمل الفلسطيني المسلح في
الاشهر الاخيره كان لمدينه جنين ومخيمها
النصيب الاكبر من الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه
منذ مطلع العام الحالي لتبلغ حتى اليوم 10
اقتحامات اسفر في مجموعها عن قتل الاحتلال
لاكثر من ثلاثين فلسطينيا نحو نصفهم من
كوادر الاذرع العسكريه التابعه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه لا سيما الجهاد الاسلامي وحركه
حماس في الثاني من يناير جاء اول
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه وتحديدا لبلده
كفردان غربيه جنين بعدها بيوم اقتحم
المخيم بهدف اعتقال مقاومين مطلوبين تبعه
في الرابع والثاني عشر والرابع عشر من
يناير اقتحامات لبل ده قباطيه جنوبيه جنين
اضافه لمركز المدينه
اما اكبر الاقتحامات فكان حين نفذت قوات
كبيره من الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليه واسعه
بمخيم جنين في السادس والعشرين من يناير
وقتلت حينها عشره فلسطينيين اختصرت
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه في فبراير على
اقتحام واحد اسفر عن قتل الاحتلال لفتن في
الرابعه عشره من عمره لتتصاعد من جديد في
مارس الجاريه حين نفذ الجيش الاسرائيلي
اقتحام لمخيم جنين في السابع من مارس اسفر
عن استشهاد سته من ابناء المخيم كما
اغتالت قوه اسرائيليه خاصه ثلاثه شبان
فلسطينيين في بلده جبع جنوبيه جنين في
التاسع من مارس الجاري